Make sure you guys hit the subscribe button.
If you guys are enjoying the content that we're throwing up and make sure you
guys hit the like button, if you enjoyed the video and yeah, let's begin.
What's going on guys.
This is Rob. And for this week's episode of our beyond Omega level series,
we're stepping into Marvel's ultimate universe and discussing one of its most
powerful mutants magician, or as I like to call him ultimate Matthew Malloy.
Here's the funny thing he kind of is,
but he kind of isn't technically he was created before Matthew Malloy, uh,
actually a while before Matthew Malloy,
Matthew malaria was introduced as part of original sin in 2014. Uh,
and this guy was introduced back in 2006, right?
So technically not the exact same character,
but you guys will see why I consider them to be very, very similar in terms of,
uh, of the characters overall, right?
So for those of you that may not be familiar with Marvel's ultimate universe,
it was an alternate reality to the main Marvel universe that was created in the
year 2000 to feature updated modern takes on classic Marvel characters without
effecting the longstanding Marvel continuity.
Now this proved to be incredibly popular with readers and the imprint ran for 15
years.
And one of the most popular titles throughout that time was the ultimate X-Men.
Now magician was introduced in issue number 66 of ultimate X-Men in 2006 by
writer, Robert Kirkman and artists, Tom Rainey.
Now magician is the codename of Elliot bogs who suddenly finds himself in a
mansion that he doesn't recognize and wonders down the hall to find his parents
had been killed.
Suddenly the police bust in the house and tell Elliott that he's responsible for
their deaths, but he also has no recollection of doing anything to them.
And so when an instant Elliot finds himself no longer in the house,
but in the middle of a field where he's immediately accosted by Nick fury of
shield.
Now Nick theory tells Elliot that he is a danger to himself and those around him
and demands Elliot come with him.
And so Elliot seems to have no clue what's going on,
but then fury tells him that he's a mutant and that his powers have manifested
overnight and are now out of control.
And so instead of agreeing to go with fury,
Elliot ends up resisting and his powers begin to manifest again,
turning the guns of,
to shield agents into snakes and causing a massive explosion. Now,
one of the shield agents hits Elliot with a tranquilizer dart and fury shows up
at Charles Xavier school with Elliot under sedation.
Now we asked Xavier to take Elliot in saying that the only other option is lucky
him away for the rest of his life due to his out of control powers,
which seems to include reality manipulation in the most extreme degree,
no ex-Navy or agrees to allow Elliot to stay.
And Elliot immediately begins asking to join the X-Men,
but sock hops tells him that he's not nearly ready as he hasn't even shown the
ability to control his powers before finally remarking that either several
months would have to pass or something really bad would have to happen before
Elliot is allowed to suit up for the X-Men. And so, as it turns out,
that's not the smartest thing to say to a person who can alter reality on a
universal scale as almost on cue Cyclops.
It gets a call from Colossus that he's been attacked by their brotherhood of
mutant supremacy.
And so psych hops allows Elliot to come along on the mission to help now,
as the X-Men battle,
the brotherhood Elliot puts his powers on display by splitting an atom,
causing an explosion powerful enough to move the blob,
which is generally thought to be completely and follows it up by moving the
earth to swallow up the blob.
He also displays the ability to alter the laws of physics.
As he decreases the gravity around the blob to effectively make him the
wait-lists before restoring it to cinema crashing back to earth.
After the X-Men to feed the brotherhood.
Elliott is interviewed by reporters who give him the nickname magician and his
interviews actually go a long way towards swaying public opinion and the X-Men
favor. And so magicians heroics also catch the eye of someone else. Nick fury,
who comes to Xavier, demanding that he be allowed to recruit Elliot to his team,
the ultimate, which are the ultimate universes version of the Avengers.
Now they get into an argument and fury threatens to get Elliot's parents
involved since he's a minor, which as you might expect,
come as a surprise to exude yer because when fury brought Elliot to a school,
one of the first things he told him is that Elliot's powers went haywire and
killed his parents.
And so when a savior confronts Nick fury on this fury says that he's never even
heard of Elliot before he saw him on television fighting alongside the X-Men.
And so they ultimately conclude that Eliot must've created an illusion of fury
bringing him to Xavier school and was able to block Charles Xavier from sensing
any of that illusion, telepathically.
They also discuss the scope of his powers and reason that the fact that they're
able to talk without Elliot influencing them must mean that he needs to be aware
of what's going on in order to manipulate it.
And so when they confront Elliot in front of the X-Men,
he says that he doesn't know what they're talking about,
but they quickly figure out that he is manipulating their minds once again.
And so the X-Men try and subdue Elliot,
but he proves himself to be far too powerful for them and also displays
inability to negate all of their powers. And so when Elliot finally comes clean,
he confesses that he'd always been a fan of the X-Men and had always wanted to
be part of the team. And so to accomplish that,
he started manipulating and deceiving everyone to make it happen.
He goes on to explain that originally he wanted to make the world,
love the X-Men, but now that they've messed up, he has to kill them all.
And so he's then confronted by Jean Gray.
Who's in possession of the Phoenix force. And so magician summons,
manifestations of the brotherhood and defeats Jean Gray,
but astound by Wolverine and vanishes without a trace with Xavier saying that
there is no trace of anything that was suggested he ever existed.
Now later Elliot appears to kitty pride whom he'd had developed a bit of a
flirtatious relationship with despite her being Spiderman's girlfriend at the
time. And he tells her that he never wanted to hurt the X-Men,
but that he was unable to exercise any control of his powers.
And so his reality warping ability,
he explains simply provides him with whatever he wants.
What did he knows it or not? And so once he wanted to join the X-Men,
he unwittingly began manipulating reality to make that happen.
And so knowing that [inaudible] would not stop coming after him,
if he knew that he was still alive,
Elliot made it so that none of them would ever know he existed including kitty
and would ultimately go somewhere that he wouldn't be a threat to anyone else
like Antarctica. And yeah,
that's pretty much everything there is to know about magician.
He only appears in a handful of issues, but in the brief time that we see him,
we see just how ridiculously powerful he can be more often than not.
When it comes to reality warping in Marvel comics,
this is done from the perspective of somebody altering intentionally, right?
Franklin Richards creates a pocket universe in his bedroom,
or he does it the aftermath of, or really as part of heroes, reborn,
where he literally creates a whole universe where all the heroes are resurrected
and live their own lives. As Franklin Richards has created them,
or as it is kind of evolve and do their own thing,
magic Jasper could ultra reality in such a way to where he could twist it and
skew it depending on what goal he wanted to achieve. Ultimately,
Jim Jasper has met,
has met his demise of the hands of the fury who could adapt to any power that
anybody had and then find a way to overcome it, right?
That's the reason why the fury teleported Jim Jasper's to a place where there
was no reality because he knew that the only way for Jim Jaspers to be as
powerful as he was, was to have a reality that to manipulate,
if there was no reality, he'd be weak. And then he just, of course,
totally incinerated it.
That's usually the way that reality warping works in Marvel comics.
What makes magician so incredibly powerful?
And what I think really kind of makes him on par and kind of the ultimate
universe version of Matthew Malloy,
is it Matthew Malloy couldn't really even control his powers and his powers
acted subconsciously. And so if Matthew Malloy wanted something,
but wasn't aware that he was triggering his powers in order to make it happen,
it would happen right now.
There were some things that Matthew Malloy did like resurrecting himself from
the dead different things like that. But with somebody like magician,
it's the exact same way his powers operate subconsciously because he doesn't
know how to control them. And so he can make anything happen.
And there's no limit to the, to the height of his powers, right?
Operating on a universal scale, possibly even beyond, right.
That's one of the good things,
or one of the interesting things about having a person with reality,
warping being powers that are so vague.
There's no definition as to what it is that he can achieve.
So with that being said, guys, we're gonna bring this video to an end.
If you are new here to comments,
explain to make sure you guys have the sub button to become part of the Rob
core. If you guys enjoyed this video, make sure you drop a, like,
I'm definitely looking forward.
Looking forward to the comments that you guys are inevitably going to leave down
there, magician versus the marquee of death magician versus Matthew Malloy,
magician versus magic. Jasper's magician versus this guy, that guy,
that guy and that guy. I know you guys are going to ask those questions.
Some of them we might even answer, but I will catch you all that.
Bruce
[inaudible].